so i'm going to speak about a model
reduction
and for instance we'll introduce a new
paradigm that
goes beyond the classical offline online
splitting which we call adaptive
enrichment
and this is a particular technique uh in
context of
large scale optimization or uncertainty
quantification problems
uh in this talk i will uh concentrate on
large scale pde constraint
optimization so let's go in i will first
shortly motivate uh by uh
posing you one of the mathematical
challenges that we dealt with
why we need more order reduction and why
we need a
particular those methods that i will
present you today
i will then shortly give a recap of the
basic introduction into to reduce basis
approaches one of the
projection based model order reduction
approaches that we have very well
developed
in some areas of pde approximation
i will then go to a particular
application where
i can demonstrate the efficiency of this
approach this is
which is modeling and simulation of
degradation processes
of lithium-ion batteries and from that
we will also see
that the classical approach has
limitations because
in the offline stage we use usually need
to solve
very large scale problems and this is
already prohibitive in a lot of
applications
i will then come to this new paradigm
for pde constraint optimization
and this is particular to introduce to
you the reduced basis trust region
approach for model order reduction of
this kind of optimization problems
and in the last step i will give an
outlook
how we can combine these techniques with
localized model order reduction which is
a
technique which is quite helpful for
large scale and
for instance multiscale problems so
let's look at one of the
mathematical challenges and this
already serves as an example that i will
later on
uh discuss the simulation of lithium-ion
batteries so if you do a simulation and
you want to look into degradation
processes then these
degradation processes they depend
actually on the local currents within
these porous
electrodes and as these local currents
change a lot depending on the geometry
this is an issue of regularity depending
on the
on the geometry of the solution you
really need
to solve these these systems in this
poor scale
geometry because homogenized
models will never be able uh to really
give you an
insight into for instance
local uh local currents
and the distribution of local currents
that are
responsible for degradation processes so
this
just as an advertisement and we want to
do model order reduction for this
because
these simulations in complex geometries
they are
quite complex and if you want to really
investigate degradation processes and
do some parameter dependent studies
then of course you need to solve a lot
of these uh
large scale problems and this is very
time consuming and we want to reduce
this
so let's come to the basic approach of
model order reduction and
this is a tool that can be used in a lot
of
different contexts like optimization
optimal control
or uncertainty quantification or
in the situation where you really want
to do real-time simulation
for parameter dependent scenario and
i just uh advertise to this
book on model reduction and
approximation where you find an overview
on
the recent developments of these tools
not only reduce basis methods but also
balance truncation
pod methods and others and the idea is
always that you look at a parameterized
problem
and if you fix a parameter then you can
compute a solution and this can be done
in the context
of pdes with any kind of
high dimensional schemes like finite
element finite volumes discontinuous
collecting whatever you have
in your lab and the task is
to approximate not only one of these
solutions but a lot of them
depending on the parameter and if you
change the parameter
and then you get such a solution
manifold of your problem
lying in an infinite dimensional or very
high dimensional space
depending whether you look at the
continuous problem or on your
highly resolved finite element model
and you want to construct a very low
dimensional space and then project
into this low dimensional space and this
is
what the reduced basis method is doing
it constructs such a low dimension space
and low dimensional means really low
this means that if your high dimension 5
element method has
1 million degrees of freedom you hope to
project in a
space that has about 100 dimensions
and then you can do very fast source in
this low-dimensional space
so there are other books recent books
that you can have a look at for the
reduced basis method and i
just to present you the major idea for
time dependent problem so we now focus
on
such a time dependent pde where
mu is a parameter dependent differential
operator
this can be hyperbolic or parabolic
problems
plus suitable initial and boundary
conditions and you always assume
that you already know how to solve these
problems
with either a finite element finite
volume or dg approximation
which gives you the possibility to
evaluate for a given parameter a high
dimensional solution
the answers for the reduced basis is now
the construction of this low dimensional
space
and then the projection of a high
dimensional scheme into this low
dimensional space
this gives you then this low dimensional
approximation
which is very fast to compute and in
order to really be to be able to do this
we need some
ingredients requirements first of all we
need
reliable and efficient error control for
the error between
the reduced solution and the high
dimensional one
and this is not only necessary to
certify
the reduced model but it's also needed
as you will see later
in order to construct this low
dimensional space because this is done
uh in our context in a greedy manner and
this greedy algorithm needs a fast
evaluation of errors
and in the time dependent context the
optimal or gold standard that we have
established
is the pod greedy i will come to this in
a minute the next step is the so-called
offline online decomposition
such that you are really able in the
online phase
to solve only small systems that have a
complexity
which is equal to the dimension of this
low dimensional space and has no
ingredients of the high dimension and
then in addition if your operator is
for instance non-linear or does not
fulfill certain
fine decomposition criteria then you
need a hyper reduction
and i will introduce shortly just one
concept which is the empirical operator
interpolation to treat
non-linearities but all this is quite
well established
so look at any finite volume these key
or discontinuities connecting scheme for
these equations then you will also
always end up into a linear system or
non-linear system to solve you have
some implicit operator some explicit
operator
some right hand side so all these uh
high dimensional schemes on the linear
algebra side
are at the end in such a format
and the reduced basis methods that's the
following so whenever
this low dimension space is constructed
and we come to this point in a minute
then this is represented by a
small basis with n basis functions
and when we assume
that the operators have a suitable
form then we can do a projection
efficiently
but first of all we just project this
high dimensional equation to this low
dimensional space and the following
way so we we spend long dimensional
solution
in this basis and then for the
coefficients
in this uh in in this uh
form we get a dis reduced
system to solve with an implicit part an
explicit part
and a right hand side and this is now
for the linear case
where you see that these these uh
projected operators are just coming
from the high dimensional operators by
projecting them
uh to the basis uh in the scalar product
that that comes with these spaces
and this can be done for the implicit
matrices for the explicit ones
and this is for the initial data and
this is for the right hand side
what you see already at that point
uh you have these small matrices here
but if you want to compute them then you
have to
solve these integrals and within the
integral you have still a parameter
dependence
this would mean that the assembly step
for these matrices has to be done
anew whenever a new parameter is picked
and this is something that we want to
avoid and this is called
offline online decomposition uh
and this offline online decomposition
can be done whenever your
operator has such a form that you can
write it as a sum
on some operator that only depends on x
and some function that only depends on
the parameter
whenever this is the case then in the
offline phase you can pre-compute
or assemble these low-dimensional
matrices
by projecting just these x-dependent
operators to your reduced space
and the new dependent part which is
summing up
these small matrices and multiply them
with these parameter dependent functions
that is a very fast step with low
complexity that you can do in the online
phase
so this is the case whenever you have a
disaffine parameter dependence
and if you don't have this dependence or
if your problem is non-linear which
forces you that
you you are not in the situation that
you can do this
then you need an additional hyper
reduction step and this is
the empirical interpolation but uh come
let's come to the
choice of the low dimensional spaces
first
with the so-called pod greedy algorithm
that i introduced together with better
hearthstone in 2008
the general idea here is that we want to
construct
from snapshots so we compute with a high
dimensional scheme
for given parameter trajectories of our
time dependent problems
and when this parameter is chosen well
which we do with a greedy algorithm
which means that
we need to have an efficient apostrophe
apostro-error estimator that we can
evaluate quickly such that we can search
in a parameter in a parameter domain
for the parameter that has worst error
with respect to the basis or the space
that we
have already constructed okay then we
compute this
time trajectory and this time trajectory
is then
reduced using a principal ordinal
decomposition p o d
so this is a very nice
scheme and the question is how good does
it perform
for instance do we have really fast
conversions like
exponential convergence with respect to
the low dimension because if you have
such a convergence this would mean that
really such a complex high dimensional
system can be reduced
to a small one with 10 to 100 parameters
so and there is a result in a
publication of my co-author
banner hearthstone in 2013 that actually
gives you a theoretical
backup for this and this theorem says
that
whenever the so-called kolmogorov
animates
which is defined here for a compact
set which is the set of solutions
depending on the parameter in our case
whenever this has an algebraic or
exponential decay
then this pod greedy algorithm will give
you an approximation with the same
decay either algebraically or
exponentially and with the same
constants
and this extends prior results in the
elliptic case
of of uh benefit island so we are in a
very
well uh position we have established a
gold standard method here for
time-dependent problems that we can
apply and with this i want to come
to this application for degradation
processes of lithium-ion batteries where
we
ex exactly take this message so this was
done within a
research project in germany where a lot
of
different partners were involved from
other universities and also from the
german
uh dlr center and fraunhofer institutes
and and
the goal was here to gain better
understanding of degradation processes
in dsmi batteries through mathematical
modeling
in particular using model order
reduction to speed up
simulation so what is uh the
model the underlying model for
distinction iron batteries
so this is very abstract but the major
model
that we look at in these resolved
electrodes
is such a system where we have a time
dependent convection diffusion equation
with those terms
for the lithium ions coupled
to an elliptic potential equation for a
potential
phi so i don't want to go into details
the only thing that you should
know from battery modeling is that
at the grain boundaries of the
electrodes
we have this electrochemical reaction
and this is modeled by butler folma
kinetics and you see here
the form of these source terms which has
exponentials inside
depending on the solution which are
strong
non-linearities that you have to resolve
and this is
why we need in addition to this pod
greedy
uh this hyper-reduction step in order to
be able to do
a fast offline online splitting for
these reduced models
so as i told you before you can write
this system
in such a form for any kind of favorite
discretization
schemes in our case we take a finite
volume
discretization with implicit time
stepping
this leads to a system of this type with
a nonlinear operator
amu now and then we apply pod greedy to
this
together with this concept of empirical
operator interpolation for this
non-linear operator a mu
that is then replaced by the
interpolated
operator that has it is a fine
decomposition
format so if we do that we can apply it
to the simulation in such complex uh
anode and cutout electrode geometries
and this is just to give you the speed
ups that we can gain with
this technology so the high dimensional
calculation here if you do charging this
charging sweep of the battery with
this resolved geometry that has about
1.7 million degrees of freedom in the
finite volume approximation
this needs something like six and a half
hours even using a
very nice algebraic multi-grid
pre-conditioner so most standard
technology
to solve the systems so
six and a half hours means that you come
into your office in the morning the
morning
you press the button to start a
simulation and you get the result
when your day is over if you apply this
reduced
technology then you see that depending
on the system size you get
an error in the order 10 to minus three
in the
relative array both components uh the
concentration of the ions and
and uh potential um and this is the
times in seconds that you get now so
which means that at most 1.5
seconds and your simulation is done
um this is a speed up in this order of
290 or
280 but it's most important that now you
can press the button for your simulation
and you get the response in 1.5 seconds
instead of six and a half hours
so this is the nice story about reduced
order modeling
what it does not tell you is that in
order to construct this low dimensional
model
you have to do these complex
computations with the
high dimension finite volume method for
several parameters
and this is time consuming so it takes a
lot of time to prepare this model
and it's also memory demanding because
you have to store these trajectories in
order to be able to do the pod
so also there there are technologies how
to deal with this
these problems using for instance
hierarchical approximate pod
instead of pod but nevertheless um
it's not just done uh to say that we
have this
very fast online methods we also need to
take care about this
high complexity and these demands in the
offline phase
so let me uh come to some insights
where we really look at these
degradation processes and one thing that
we looked at is
lithium plating so you see in this harsh
cell
geometry in this green particles uh
the currents are so large that uh
that the lithium goes to a metallic
phase and starts to grow
which is called lithium plating and we
also wanted to simulate
these things with our reduced models
uh this is a more complex model that i
then
than that what i showed you before and
in particular we needed an apostrophe
error estimate
estimation for these complex models
which is not right away
available and there i just wanted to hit
you
towards the possibility to
do hierarchical error estimation instead
of residual error estimation this was
presented in a paper with heinrich and
urban in 2019
which relies on the fact that you look
at reduced spaces
that are embedded into a larger space
and you compute now the difference
between the reduced simulation for
a given accuracy with a better one
so with which a lot with a larger space
um and if this if this is done
then you get really um error estimates
that you can use
without further theory just relying on
the fact
that we have this kind of exponential
convergence
um which then allows you that this uh
to to say that this saturation
assumption that we have here is really
uh
satisfied so with this uh kind of
hierarchical apostrophe error estimation
we look at this uh
complex problem with lead simulating and
we compare here
um the error and the real relative error
with the
approximated relative error with this
hierarchical indicator so the
uh the dots are the approximated errors
and
the the lines are the exact arrows and
you see that you get a quite
a very nice fit of this error estimate
with the real error
and if you look at the solutions and
this is a comparison
of such a plating problem for
a high dimensional model with the
reduced model the high dimensional model
is the underlying line
and the reduced one is the the crosses
that you see on top of these lines
and you see that in this uh physically
irrelevant regime
where you have the plating you get to
this behavior here in this uh
plot where we plot the transfer charge
against the cell voltage
and also this quite interesting physical
phenomena
phenomena is very well captured by
the reduced model so this is for one of
the outputs the other one is the
transferred
charge against the average lithium
concentration
and also there you see that all the
features are really kept
by this reduced model so so
so much to the classical reduced basis
let me advocate a little bit uh our
software framework that we use for model
order reduction this is a python package
which is called
plymouth it's an open source uh package
that is
available on this by more web page and
the main
maintainers are very milk stuff and
felix schindler from my group and
this model reduction is on top of any
high dimensional server package that you
use so there is an interface concept
that you can use this this package
together with your favorite
server package and there are already
implemented interfaces
for the dual package for d2 for phoenix
for engisolf
and others can be implemented following
these
python bindings that are already there
so just this is the framework that we
use for model order reduction we split
the implementation work between the high
dimensional one
and the reduced algorithms so let me
come
to the new part which is this pde
constraint optimization
using new ideas of adaptive enrichment
so this is a work where we have
already uh two preprints one
appeared in june last year the other one
in december last year
i will concentrate in the presentation
here um on the first work
from from june uh in the second one we
added uh
as a sub solver for the optimization
problems
a newton scheme so we compute also
hashing information as i will point out
later
so let's go into the context of pde
constraint optimization that we are
looking at
so we look at objective functionals
depending on
a state and a parameter and here we have
a particular form we take
so linear functions and also such
bi-linear functionals and parts that
only depend on parameter
that we want to minimize subject to a
state equation which means that the
state u
is satisfied satisfies a variational
problem um
and we uh for simplicity first
concentrate here on the stationary case
where we just look at such a coercive
variational problem
let's say an elliptic problem like
porous media equation or something like
that
so if we come into this context and
usually if you want to solve this
optimization problem
during the optimization solve you need
to
calculate a lot of state problems
forward problems
and in order to calculate derivative
information for this
objective function which means gradient
with respect to the parameter
or the hessian information you even have
to
either compute sensitivity
sensitivities which means
derivatives of the solution with respect
to the parameter
or you can do the concept of first
optimize then discretize and you get
the gradient usually from solving the
dual
equation and using this for the
computation of the
of the gradient and this is what we will
do in the following
and we want to use optimized model order
reduction
to speed up this optimization process so
if you
so this is just just a list of
references
of other works that dealt with which is
basis methods and model order reduction
i will come later for instance to this
article of
kian kappel veroy and wilcox where they
first introduced a method that is quite
similar to what we do here and we come
to the differences in a moment
so if you look at the classical reduced
basis approach
like i told you before with online
offline splitting
and you compare this approach with the
full order
approximation in the context of
optimization problems
then you see the following behavior so
let's
look first at the blue line this is a
newton full order model
which means that you have a newton
iteration
and in each of these newton iterations
you solve
your pde with a high dimensional finite
element model
and then of course you iterate and
iterate until you really reach a point
where the newton method reaches
its high conversion speed and then you
get a very fast
decay towards the optimum so if you now
compute the same
method just by replacing the full order
model by this reduced orders surrogate
model
then you see that you have starting here
a very fast convergence
so it it takes a little really like
nothing
but there is a huge time cpu time
that you need in order to construct this
reduced model in the offline phase with
the greedy or
pod greedy algorithm and this means that
you prepare this reduced model not just
for solving this optimization problem
but you prepare it to be
be good for the whole parameter range
and then you can use it very fast online
but you have to pay
first a lot in order to get this model
and this is something that we want to
avoid in the following and this is the
idea
how we want to do that so let's suppose
for simplicity
that we just have a two-dimensional
parameter domain in the
parameter direction x and y
and you want to solve this optimization
problem and
the optimum is some parameter mu bar and
you start
with some arbitrary chosen initial
parameter mu0
and you want to go somehow with your
iterative optimization solver
from this initial point in the parameter
space
to this optimum and you see already here
depending on the way you have to go
either straight or taking uh
some different way you do you do not
need
the underlying model in the full
parameter domain you just
need it around this path that the
optimizer takes
to go from mu0 to mu bar you
only need it in this area and this is
the major idea
and this is what's what the trust region
method does
so trust region means that you replace
your global problem by the solution
iterative solution of local sub-problems
and these local sub problems are to be
solved within
a trusted region around the parameter
point
that you have currently selected with
your optimization server so if you start
at the beginning
then we define with some suitable
apostrophe error estimates
a trust region which is such a ball with
a radius
delta zero and this means that the
reduced model that we created here
has a certain accuracy just in this
region
around mu zero so we can solve a sub
problem
optimization sub problem within this
thrusted region until we hit the
boundary
and this is the new parameter and again
we have to check whether our local model
is accurate enough in such a trusted
region and we can do the next
optimization step
if you follow this principle then in
each of these optimization
steps you do just an enrichment of the
local
reduced model such that it is
certified in this small region within
the large parameter domain
and it's not a model that is good enough
for carrying the whole parameter range
okay so the idea is that we choose
in this address region optimization as a
local
model function the reduced objective
functional
which is then just the objective
for our reduced basis approach
and this was already done in this work
of
kian krebs wilcox that i announced you
before so you
take as a model function uh just a
reduced functional using a
a suitable reduced basis base and this
reduced basis base is then enriched from
step to step
and this means that this model function
changes with this iteration index k
from step to step due to the change the
changing
reduced model which is below as a sub
problem solver for these local
optimization problems
we take a pfgs method which
needs the evaluation of the gradient
information
information of the function but not the
exact question that the hessian is
approximated there
so what we are now doing new is
first of all i will show you that the
result presented here was not
optimal and we have to give an
alternative
and there we come to a so-called
non-conforming dual
corrected approach we correct
with respect to the evaluation of the
objective functional
and the derivative of the objective
function
and then i will show you that this gives
really a better
speed up also for the resulting scheme
so what we have to do in order to apply
this whole procedure we have to look at
the full optimality system
of this optimization problem which means
we have the primal state equation and we
formulate a residual of the primal state
we have sensitivities
which are the derivatives of the
solution with respect to the parameters
by solving such problems
with respect to the residuals we have a
dual state equation
we have the residuals for the dual
states we have dual
dual sensitivities that we compute and
finally
with all these contributions we can
compute
a reduced gradient of the objective
function
so this is all the problems that we need
to solve
and we actually then also need a
rigorous apostrophe error estimate for
each of these equations
if we now come to the projection on the
low dimensional space
then we construct in general
different reduced spaces for the primal
problem
for the dual problem for the primal
sensitivities and the dual sensitivities
and as you see here this leads to the
case that
the dual solution pmu
which lies in this dual space is not
a test function that you can use in the
primal equation
and this problem this is a
non-conformity that comes from
adjusting the spaces to the problems
here
which is usually not visible if you just
use a uniform a high dimensional
discretization which is the same for the
prime lender tool
but you need to take care of this
non-conformity
that comes with this approach and this
uh
makes it necessary to look carefully at
the
evaluation of the reduced objective
functional that i define here which is
the lacrosse functional
with respect to the reduced model and if
you evaluate this
then it has these two contributions and
in this work of
gun couple and
wilcox there was only this component and
this residual was neglected and if you
look at this residual
then you see exactly that we use as a
test function the solution of the dual
problem here
and if they were from the same space
then this residual would be zero
and it would be gone but this is not the
case here so we need
to do this correction in order to have
the right like call functional here and
this has some
advantages as we will see because this
corrected functional here
has a faster convergence rate than the
original one
that you just take by a naive approach
so what we do now is that we really want
to solve this
reduced minimization problems with
respect to this corrected
functional here and then
we compute error estimates rigorous
apostrophe error estimates for all these
quantities
so the error in the primal in the dual
in the functional
in the gradient of the function and in
this insensitivities and we can give
rigorous apostrophe our estimates for
all of them
but i want to focus just on the
approximation of the
functional and the gradient here because
this is new
because of this correction step so and
what you see
here is that for the error in the
objective functional
with respect to this ncd corrected
functional
we really get contributions in the
apostrophe error estimate
which are which has the contributions
this is the error estimate for the
primal this again
and you see this appears quadratic here
with a constant
and in the first part this is a replaced
with some dual residual that you compute
which is also such a quadratic
part here so whenever you have
convergence of the primal and the dual
then you then you get here with this
correction step
that the objective functional um
converges
in a quadratic manner with respect to
the primal and lingual problem
and also if you look at the gradient
information
then we get an apostrophe error estimate
which is now a little bit more involved
but also shows
this very nice convergence properties
you will see this in the numerics later
so again we are now back um and i told
you about this
algorithm and in each step we enrich the
spaces
and there are now different choices for
the primal dual
spaces and also the sensitivity spaces
you can take
all of them separately and adjust it to
the particular equations
but you can also look at so-called
tailored
tailored are b spaces where the spaces
for the primal problem and their
derivatives
are accumulated in one space
which is similar to not taking just a
lagrangian approach but hermit
approach for the spaces so this is also
something that we tried
or you can accumulate all these spaces
and use the same space for everything
and then of course
you don't need this correction in the
residual
in the objective function anymore so but
you will see as we we showed this is a
bad choice because the approximation
properties are
then not so nice so
um we also can show a convergence
of the trust region optimization method
with this nct
corrected approach so this is again now
this local transcreation optimization
problem
where you solve in each step your primal
state equation
with respect to the given reduced space
and you have a stopping criteria for
this iteration to solve this
optimization problem which is giving
a given here so you prescribe a
tolerance
for for solving the optimization problem
and this is the error in the parameter
of this optimization problem
and in addition you check that the
relative
error in your objective functional um
is within the given radius
of the trusted region so this is this
means that the
method that you you use here is really
within the trust region
and then you can show that this method
convergence
converges uh towards the optimum
one of the optimum local accumulation
points
so whenever you have uniqueness of the
overall global problem then
then you get convergence against the
unique optimum with an error which is
just a given tolerance that you
impose in the scheme so let me
demonstrate this
for a very simple model problem which
comes
from the common room that you see here
of our cluster of excellence
administer so whenever you visit us here
you will get a coffee here
and we look at a model problem that we
derive
from that looking at such an objective
function
um with respect to let's say a
stationary heat
transport given by this elliptic pte
and what we solve here is seen in the
second slide
so we take the
construction from this cluster building
with
the common room that you see here and as
an optimization
problem we want to have a defined
temperature in one of the rooms which is
indicated in green here
and we have a lot of heaters they are
marked with with these
points here and windows and all the
parameters
for for heat
convection enter into this model as
parameters mu i
so which means you can optimize heaters
and windows and walls
in order to get optimal temperature
temperature distribution inside
and you see for a particular choice of
parameters
the heat conductivities are given like
this and so you see
that there are windows and there are
walls and
um you have the source term which is one
of the heaters for instance and then you
get
a certain primal and dual solution so
this is the setup of the problem
and then you want to solve this
optimization problem that gives you a
defined
temperature in one of the rooms so
we compare now um our new method with
the
non-conforming corrected functional
with the original one which was given
in this paper of gyan and krebel and you
see
that here in yellow
you have the convergence of both the
objective functional
and of the
of the error estimator um for the
original functional so this is this line
you see that the real error and the
error estimator for this
function lie on top of each other but
they have the wrong conversions rate
because you did not
consider this correction that you need
to consider and if you need
if you take this correction into a count
and this is this
real error and the error estimator here
then you see that
you get really desire convergence which
means that you have really
an order of magnitude difference between
this reduced functional here and the
other one and the same is
true if you look at the gradient
information and also here
the red ones are the gradient
information from
uh real error and an error estimate from
the original
approach and the other ones are those
that we get
with our new approach and if you look at
the overall
convergence of the scheme and this comes
back
to the slide that i had before where i
showed you
the comparison with the classical
offline online splitting
reduce basis method in this approach
here
you go with the trust region with the
enrichment and very fast
you have already a good model and you
don't need
enrichment anymore and you see a very
fast convergence
and this means that by comparing here
the cpu time
against the error you have no offline
phase you immediately start with this
method
that combines the full order method
and the reduced order method and thus an
enrichment of the space
in each optimization step and you get a
very fast convergence and
if i uh plot this uh
convergence from the offline splitting
then we would be
at this point and the red curve is just
solving the optimization problem with
the high order full order model
so you see that we really get very very
fast convergence and if you use the
non-corrected approach
from this work of john kepler-verroy
then this is the blue curve
this is already a quite nice
approximation but you get
even higher speed up by using this
correction step
so this was uh online enrichment for
optimization problems
in the next step we want to combine this
with localized model order reduction
which means that we do not want to
construct reduced models for the overall
computational domain
but just for sub domains like in a
domain decomposition
approach and this has already been done
and introduced
for instance in this paper with the
felix schindler 2015
in the context of discontinued skeleton
schemes but there are a lot of
additional contributions and there is a
recent review
paper in a handbook done by
andreas um smetana where you have an
overview
on this technology of localized model
order reduction
for this localized model order reduction
you need
localized error control and one
instance of such an error estimate from
this article
is shown here where you see that in this
error estimate
you have local contributions on the sub
domain so capital t
are now the sub domains that you can
compute
and this allows that you
compute local spaces for instance for
such a
test problem and
then by just computing local sub
problems you can
construct a space and then you have a
reduced model you can solve it you can
check with this localized
error estimate whether the model is good
enough and if it's not
then you can use local sub problem
enrichment steps in order to improve the
model
and you come to a certain quality of
your simulation without
ever touching a full order approximation
for the global
problem at all so for this simple
example with a compliant cost functional
we already did this approach of
combining localized model reduction with
optimization
and this is what you see in the
comparison here
so on the left hand side this would be a
classical approach with offline online
splitting
where in the offline phase the greedy
algorithm
algorithm searches for certain
parameters in this two-dimensional
parameter space
and at at this points it computes the
snapshot
and adds it to the bases and if you do
this
um by a certain quality control then you
get
this in a purple
shaded form of the objective functional
and you see
the optimum is somewhere here but you
also see
that if you start in a certain point
with your optimization tool
um this tool will follow a certain path
towards the optimum
and you will actually not need to have
good quality
of the space everywhere but just along
this
trajectory and this is what we then do
is
in this enrichment approach with the
local enrichment
we detect in the with the greedy
algorithm uh first
starting parameter of the optimization
loop and we do this local enrichment in
in a lot of steps until we reach a
certain quality
then we do one step in the optimization
we reach a different parameter
we check whether the space is already
good enough
here it's not we do an additional
enrichment step we can go to the next
one
we can do an additional enrichment step
and these enrichments are now
just solving local problems in some of
the sub domains not in all of them
and we converge and if you look at this
procedure so this is now the
partitioning
these are the subdomains that we used
and you see
the distribution of the size of basis
functions that were constructed in this
in this overall optimization loop you
see
you have a maximum of 22 basis functions
in some areas and you have
very few basis functions in other areas
in the overall optimization problem for
for this process
for this problem here we did a 709
local enrichment which means in order to
solve the global problem
we had to solve 709 such local sub
problems in order to come
up with a solution of the overall
optimization problem
without ever touching the full order
model on the global domain
in average this means on each local
domain for the overall optimization we
just solve
something like 11 problems on subdomains
of course we now develop this for the
full trust region approach which means
that we have to go through all these
upholstery error estimates uh with this
localization strategy that's what we are
currently doing
and with this um i'm at the end
i think for your attention and of course
i thank my co-authors
and if you're interested also in using
our software
the high dimension simulations are
always done in the
june the distributed unified numerics
environment framework
and the model order reduction within our
polymorph package
thanks a lot thank you so much for the
great talk professor oberger
i really enjoyed it we do have
one questions from chat room
um let me read it to you
it's from john ragusa from texas a
m when generating the full order
snapshots one
may have to use locally refined meshes
for example phase field simulations
these locally refined
grids will be different for each
parameters
and when how uh so for that um
for that context how can you apply this
reduce spaces method when snapshot
vector is uh
so the question the classical technology
here uh
deals with the same spaces for all
parameters the same number of degrees of
freedom
but this is clearly true that if you
want to have a
fair comparison then also your full
order model should
include adaptive mesh refinement and
then with this adaptive mesh refinement
of course you have a different spaces
from one parameter to the next one and
if you want
then to come up with an overall reduced
model
then you have to embed these spaces into
let's say a larger common space which is
usually the finest union
of all these uh measures and then
with this technology of course you can
then also do this reduced basis and
there are contributions where this has
been done
uh for instance the work of masayuko
yanov for instance uh
did this where he uses uh adaptive
meshing together with model order
reduction i did not present this
uh technology is there from the
mathematical point
this is no great deal but from
implementation point of view this is a
deal
so this is clear thank you
another question is coming from srida um
has uh the two questions first question
is could you tell more about
how you define the trust region radius
it seems that choice would limit the
step sizes you would
choose for your optimization part let's
let's go answer the first question first
um so
let's come to this point so for instance
also in the paper that
we presented we give the possibility
that this radius this delta
is not o it can also uh grow it can get
larger because i mean if you go on this
way and you enrich then it might be that
your model becomes
better and better and you can really
enlarge this radius and this was not in
in this paper of jana and keppel they
only had the possibility to shrink the
radius
but we showed that it's really necessary
to also enlarge these radius
in order to get a real good performance
and the major criteria that we use
for defining this radius is
this size which is the relative error
of the approximation of the objective
functional
that we can evaluate very fast using the
apostrophe error estimate
so this is the one one thing that we use
to define the radius
and the other part is that we actually
look
during the optimization solve
for the increment from um from one step
to the next um
how large is the increment that we that
we
that we have in in the solution of this
optimization problem and this
information is also used
so if you look um in uh
into the the article that i cited then
you find
let me just give this reference so there
you find a detailed algorithm that
includes the definition of the radius
and also the possibility to to enlarge
it
in this process of optimizing okay
thank you and the second question from
srider is if you can go to page 40
slide 40 okay
okay all right there you go um okay the
the convergence rates for the adders are
curious
in the figure in the left it seems that
ncd
corrected approach stops earlier
whereas the other approach leads to
smaller errors
and also in and also in the right side
figure
why does the method of kian result in
much smaller error
or was it the objective function on the
y-axis
no actually we give to the optimization
solver
this stopping criteria which is here on
top
this is the result for a stopping
criteria 10 to the minus 4
and this for 10 to the minus 6
this is this tau that we had in the
convergence algorithm
and what you see is that if you use um
the original method from the paper of
kian krebel
then actually this error estimate
has for the objective function has not
the right convergence order and this
means that
uh in such cases it might even stagnate
and stop and and and not converge
uh further because you end with the
stopping condition just because
the overestimation of the error is too
large and this problem is not there with
the methods that
that we introduce with this correction
and the difference that this stops here
earlier
and the other go deeper this is because
we have
this this finer tolerance 10 to the
minus 6 here
and you see with this finer tolerance
also the other algorithm
finally converges but it continues to
iterate here
because the error estimator does not
tell you that you already reach this
tolerance
okay well thank you that's all i have
from the chat room but that doesn't mean
that
you can unmute yourself and ask
questions if you
if you have a question please please
admit yourself and
ask questions directly
okay well i do have a
questions okay so for for the uh
enrichment um
uh the profs process how expensive is
that
um i'm assuming some computational
quality is involved with uh
yes so but whenever you do a one of
these iterations
um you check whether your model is
already good enough
and if not you compute one full order
approximation and you add this to the
primal
state uh to the primal space and to the
dual space which means uh that
that's what you see here at the
beginning from one step to the next step
the cost is about the same as for the
full order model because in each of
these
initial steps you always have to solve
solve the full order model
this is why at the beginning this is
more or less following the full order
convergence
but then you come into a situation where
due to this enrichment this space was
already good enough
and you do not have to do this
enrichment in every optimization step
and this is where you now really profit
from this method and you get
this fast convergence and if you look at
the
computational cost then the cost for the
solution of the full order model this is
the high
cost that you have if you add this to
the low dimensional space
then this means that for the local model
you really
just need to compute additional
components of the localized operators
and this is very fast
so the major work that you have to do is
the full order model source this is what
what has the computational cost nice
nice okay um i guess another question
from me
is um so another like active research
area
in reduced automobile community is uh
something
to do with a slow decay in chromograph
with and
i'm i'm assuming um the all the examples
you have shown
has as fast decay in komodo with
and yeah right so these problems they
have
a fast decay it's just that if you
look at this complex problems um
like uh it is complex geometry these
multiscale problems
um then it might be that the solution
manifold is already quite rich
but you are still in the situation that
you have the fast decay
but of course it's uh of quite some
importance to look
uh at an improvement of these methods
for like hyperbolic problems with uh
with shock forms where you do not have
these fast convergence of kolmogorov
with
and i think it's clear that their
additional ingredients
need to be included because then
you will never beat the kolmogorov dk
with a linear method and this means
that you have to go to nonlinear
approaches
and this can either be uh done by
introducing a deformation of snapshots
and there are a lot of contributions
that go into this direction
or recent approaches like lee and
karlberg
using the neural networks with outer
encoders
where auto encoders can be seen as a
non-linear version
of a singular value decomposition so
it's a nonlinear generalization of the
pod
in the end so there are a lot of these
approaches currently a lot of teams
working on that
but up to now there is none of them with
a real serious
mathematical justification so this is
something that is still
missing okay i just wanted to add that
uh
from in our group uh we have improved
the
lian covers uh the non-linear map
reduced model
achieving the speed up by applying the
hyper reduction
i just wanted to mention that okay
um any other um questions
from audience
i noticed that under maxwell i was
may want to ask some questions and i
heard some noise from him
no i don't uh have any questions
okay thanks for asking yeah
okay that's good um
any other questions from audience
uh if not then we can thank our today
speaker
uh the professor berger thank you so
much for the great
talk it was very interesting i'm sure
that um
i hope that there will be some follow-up
questions and
you don't mind you know getting the
questions from
us and answering those yeah
feel free to contact me and i'm happy to
answer all the questions
okay awesome awesome thank you so much
um
the protestor burger okay fine so have a
nice day
okay with that we will conclude our uh
today's
gdpr seminar okay thank you so much for
joining us today
okay bye bye thanks